welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
companion bonus worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 22 and we're gonna learn how you can
generate more sales
[Music]
I'm gonna give you Mark Cuban rule
number 1 and whenever you forget this
rule you're already out of business in
every business sales Cure's all has
anybody ever heard of a business that
had zero sales sales that was successful
doesn't happen yet a lot of people start
their business thinking I have a great
idea I'm gonna do this this is amazing
I'm gonna go raise money I just sold
this idea and then it comes back and
it's like okay you gotta sell that
product or you got to sell that service
that's the first main key to a
successful business when you're getting
ready to start you have to answer that
question and for like an entrepreneur
not a salesperson I'm not just an
entrepreneur we're looking to start a
business well if you can't sell if you
can't influence if you can't persuade
good luck trying to get your business
off the ground I'm not so just your
customers I'm talking about the bankers
the people are venture capitalists your
vendors your credit card processor the
people who work for you how do you get
people to work for you excited how do
you get them excited to get into wanna
buy into your vision at the highest
level what sales really is it's the
transference of emotion and the emotion
you're transferring is this emotion of
certainty that someone feels certain yet
it's a good thing it's gonna help me
it's gonna fill my need when you're an
entrepreneur you're trying to start a
business and you're recruiting people
well you're selling people on your
vision for the future your vision for
this company if you can't do that good
luck trying to get great people to work
for you it's very it's almost it's
nearly impossible which is why you what
we see you know the people if they say
oh he's a visionary well that's true but
typically not only they visionaries they
also possess the ability to sell the
vision to other people to inspire them
to motivate them so selling is not just
like you know people think of selling oh
well a lot of salesmen
well yes you do you need to learn how to
influence how not trying to get your
kids to make their bed or do that
homework or believe in the value of
education how about trying to get a
landlord give you a reduction on your
rent ought to extend the lease of the
way you want had not trying to negotiate
currency understand it's it cuts to
everything so I always look at the say
you know what when I say I crack the
code on influence what I really did
essentially was I just I was you know by
working backwards almost by saying I'm
just thought at the end and go to the
beginning say what has to happen before
someone says yes I was ill to take that
and put it into this system that took
the no name talentless guys and turned
them into millionaires I am very shy
very very shy and I came back from
Vietnam and I could kill people but I
couldn't talk to people and one day I
said to my my decided to follow my rich
dad's footsteps I just said to him I
want to be an entrepreneur he says you
got one problem I said what's that so if
you're shy I said what's wrong with
being shy he says you gotta sell you got
to handle rejection number-one skill
can you handle rejection answers no I
couldn't handle it so I stole that wall
arrow itself so without this is the 1973
I was 25 years old and my Rich Dad said
how's your love life so that sucks so
you're getting laid they said no so this
but you can't sell guys got it
so when I talk about what skill do you
need when the [ __ ] hits the fan
you better start selling so I went to
work for Xerox in 1974 like I learned
how to sell it took me four years and I
was number one okay and today I'm a
best-selling author
you know most PhD is telling me I can't
write yes I said I can't write but I
can't sell if you can't sell you don't
make money period and the statement you
know just because you have a product
doesn't mean jack but the important
thing is you start you know I don't care
what product you start with but you
start and I started off with dialog
wallets success wiped me out you know we
couldn't sell could itself also it took
off then I couldn't finance I put in
finance to put in finance but the sales
kept going through the roof now trouble
is I kept borrowing and they couldn't
sustain the sales next less but that's
how we learn okay your first customer is
the most difficult thing you'll ever do
as a business person in my experience to
find someone who will actually pay you
that first time phasing to your mom yeah
well that's right that isn't a family
member that's an actual customer and the
the other problem that people face when
they're trying to sell a new product is
one of the reasons one of the ways that
people decide whether they're going to
buy something is whether or not a they
know anyone else who's already bought it
or B if there's other people in their
domain that are already using it and if
if your sales pitch is well know this is
new and revolutionary you think well
that's a wonderful sales pitch it it's
like it is if you're talking to someone
who's entrepreneurial and risk-taking
and interest and interested in
revolutionary ideas but if you're
talking to a middle manager in a company
the last thing that person wants to hear
is well you could be a risk taker and
introduce this into your company the
person's thinking I don't want to put my
job
a petition on the line for your product
even if it is revolutionary in part
because if it succeeds I probably won't
be rewarded for its success so when we
were selling our or employee selection
software for example we ran it we were
academics or and so you know there was
lots of things we didn't know about
business and one of the things we ran
into which was so funny we talked to the
people who were doing the hiring and
they had a certain budget which was
usually lower than because they had
virtually no budget for hiring weirdly
enough so what we were charging for the
product which was still extremely modest
exceeded their budget said well look
you're gonna make a 250 fold return on
this that's that's the pessimistically
it's 50 realistically it's 250 and the
upper end was more like 500 so it's a
no-brainer to implement this it's like
well we're budgeted on the cost side
what do you mean well if we if we hire
more productive employees we won't be
rewarded for that
we'll just be punished for spending more
money no it's that I thought well we
can't even talk to you because I'm
trying to sell you something that will
benefit your company but for you
as the decision maker there's nothing
but risk and implementing the new
process yes that just blew me away it's
like oh I see
the hiring budget and the productivity
budget aren't associated that's like a
fatal impediment to to our sales process
you know our children finish
undergraduate school and they both work
before they went on to graduate school I
told both Kelly and Derek makes 300 cold
calls a day and you'll lead the nation
in sales or in anything you do 300 cold
calls a day and that's getting through
to somebody not leaving a message by
bavette and they both did you cannot
even if you're a [ __ ] like you guys if
you made 300 legitimate cold calls
you'll make a million dollars a year no
problem and that's not a lot of money
and I say that be grudgingly but to most
people it is that's 12 that's 1,500 cold
calls a week that's 6000 cold calls a
month
72,000 cold calls a year if you can't
make a minute now you ought to kill
yourself metaphorically speaking how do
you manage the indecisive client good
question
there's I broke down as much as I could
you know how there's like the six stages
of grief and then like the types of
tornadoes like I always when I got into
the business really kind of thought of
sales like the six stages of selling
like what emotional clients go through
because they go through their grieving
period like their denial period they're
excited period and you have to walk them
through all those steps and the best
salespeople are the ones who can
anticipate it like an ER doctor like
they know like when this next emotional
phase is gonna hit so you can prepare
how your conversation is going to lead
into that moment kind of like a
psychologist right but people who are
indecisive or people who are insecure
about the decision that they're gonna
make anyway like at the end of the day a
lot of indecisive people we know they
end up making a decision they're just
really self-conscious or insecure about
their intelligence or something and you
have to help them get comfortable and
figure out how to get there and a lot of
it is just laying out options so kind of
the way I just talked to you about first
impressions and it could have been super
boring but I've made it relative by
talking about dating in a bar and then
people laugh and they're like oh that is
kind of the same way Oh interesting same
thing with people who are indecisive
you know it's figuring out a way to make
it relatable to them and like if you
have a client or a boss or somebody you
figure out what they like to do
personally so you track them on social
media let's say and you figure out that
they really like cats okay or they
really like golf or they're really into
the Jets I don't know something like
that you try to without telling them
that you internet stalk them you figure
out in your conversation with them how
to make whatever the situation is you're
talking about it relatable to something
they really like like you know this is
you know I understand you want to take
your time but if Sam Darnell had taken
his time you know on his first game out
might not have won that first game huh
and then that guy is gonna be like dude
you're a Jets fan like I mean sure yeah
now I am
Oh crazy yeah anyway the real reason I
don't want to do this is because of XY
and Z because now it's on a personal
level now they're thinking about
something they really like plus you made
it relatable it's just how you present
that information versus that sales
person who just says can I help you with
anything no ok let me know if you need
anything
great that's most people my friends were
graduating from us UCLA and they were
getting a $40,000 year's salary after
going to school after spending 150 grand
on college and I'm working at Bally's
and I had made $5,000 in a month and I
said wait a minute
my friends spent $150,000 to go to
college I don't have a degree and I just
made $5,000 in a month huh
maybe the most important skill set to
make money in America sales and by the
way step number one to creating wealth
is learning how to sell before you hang
the video and change it and go to
another video hear me out and be able to
disagreement and say I don't agree with
you hear me out here in every single
family there's political matters yes you
probably had some political matters when
somebody dies who's gonna get this who's
gonna get that there's always political
matters you know who typically wins the
one who knows how to sell you know who
typically dates and marries that
beautiful girl that every guy wanted to
be with the guy that don't set itself
that's simple you know at your job have
you ever had anybody that got a
promotion over you that wasn't qualified
but they got it over you you know why
because they know how to sell and you
don't know how to sell and if you don't
know how to sell your salaries at 58
she's at 79 you think it's important
you're on how to sell maybe it's some
poor learning how to sell you see most
salespeople they always believe in the
conventional wisdom in order to be a
great salesperson what do you have to do
you have to have enthusiasm you got to
be excited about your product hey man is
it this is my product it's so good don't
you know we are the best in the world
this would help you this will help your
company you should buy it from me
enthusiasm because they are taught if
you're not enthusiastic about your
product or service and then the prospect
won't be enthusiastic either or what I
call pretentious bonding hey you know
how your kids yeah how's the weather
how's work you don't give a [ __ ] you
know your prospect doesn't give it but
it's pretentious bonding or
oh you gotta follow a man you know they
buy or they die right you fall up 5 10
30 times you're gonna be persistent you
gotta keep calling keep calling keep
chasing them or you gotta ask for the
sale three times the average sell
prospect you gotta ask them seven times
before they buy I don't like to ask for
the sell I want the prospect that give
me the cell it's better to receive than
the bag or you got to chase the prospect
you got to keep pleasing them chase them
I don't like to chase someone I like to
be the chase so how do you become a
great salesperson today I'm gonna give
you one of the most important lessons
that I have learned in order to be a
great salesperson and that is now this
may sound counterintuitive that is in
order to be a great salesperson you
cannot be a salesperson what Dan what
are you talking about I want to think
about in a society when I say the word
sales what comes to mind when I say the
word salesperson what comes to mind
comment below no filter don't think
about it just comment below sales or
salesperson what comes to mind snake oil
pushy aggressive used-car salesman
manipulation right just do it for the
money
once your commission all that stuff
right imagine if you have kids imagine
if you I parent mom and dad your kid
goes home and walks up to you and say
hey dad daddy mommy when I grow up I
want to be a doctor and you're like oh
my god dad I'm so proud of you
you know I raised you well it's good
you'll be a talked to him right imagine
different scenario your kid comes home
and says dear mommy and daddy when I
grew
I want to be a Salesman and you're like
oh my god what did I do
this is how I raised you I fail I fail
as a parent what did I do
right just think about that so it's
perfectly okay to get into student loan
to spend six eight years in medical
school right to pick a highly stressed
out profession don't get me wrong I have
a lot of respect for doctors but somehow
when your kid comes home and say I want
to be a salesperson is all it is such a
profession they're being looked down
upon that is a profession that is like
no that is not a real job and it's not a
real career when in fact some of the
highest paid people in our society
guess what their salespeople one puffit
it's a salesperson Elon Musk is a
salesperson when Elon Musk is announcing
the new Tesla guess what he is closing
he's a closer he's selling right when
Warren Buffett at the shareholder
meeting talks about the division talk
about what they're gonna do talk about
the report talk about the earnings guess
what he is selling so you invest in a
stock remember Steve Jobs when he was
announcing the new iPhone the new iPod
in front of thousands and thousands of
people live in worldwide the whole world
is watching guess what
he is closing that is a sales
presentation it's not a product
announcement it's a sales presentation
they are all closers they all sales
people so how do you become a great
salesperson don't sound and act and talk
like a typical salesperson if a typical
salesperson it's like hey hey how are
you sir don't do that become be neutral
sound like a doctor imagine that you are
a doctor they imagine go to a doctor and
your doctor says to you how are you
glad you could come in how do you feel
you have a fever hey no worry man you
know what I can do it Chris scripture in
fact this prescription you buy when you
get one free man is so good
you where you want me to follow with you
if you see a doctor and the doctor signs
like that what do you do you write there
is something wrong with this guy right
be the doctor calm neutral don't chase
be the chase
be a problem-solver ask questions
discover their needs be a professional
me tell me a little bit about your
situation tell me about your business
let's bottom line just tell me how you
and I can do business today what we
hoping to get for me today see that's a
professional that's how you should
behave and talk your tonality you speak
with conviction and authority yet you're
not attached to yourself it's okay if
you don't get to sell see when you're
not desperate now the prospect they open
they open up to you now they want to
hear okay this person wants to help me
not just going after the money or the
Commission check or that the quick buck
that this person is a professional that
you are a professional that's how you
sell your way through life that's how
you get what you want in life by first
helping others to get what they want
then you can get everything that you
want it is that simple first thing you
got to get right if you want to be in
the sales game today is you got to get
your freaking financial literacy right
you got to get your money financial
mindset right you got to start thinking
about taking your finances from the
level you are to the level where you and
your family deserve to be and you know
this is true
okay people that are not making enough
money simply make sense of why they're
not making enough money money's not
gonna make me happy I'm fine where I am
I'm doing better than people that live
in Afghanistan okay well none of that
makes sense if you had the potential to
make more money if you have a great
product a great company and you know
another call another strategy one more
little maybe angle something that you
could persist with if you know that you
be making more money and you aren't
let's get that fixed okay and the first
thing to becoming a millionaire a
multi-millionaire i Hecht a millionaire
or a billionaire and I've spent time
with enough billionaires now is they
have made decisions to get their money
right okay whether they're going public
or selling a product scaling out they
had to make a decision to get the money
the finance model of their household
their business their product or their
IPO right right if they want to go to
the market and become a public company
so number one get your money right it's
not about product knowledge first it's
not about sales knowledge first it's not
about sales process first it's not about
to follow up first or right in the
customer up first it's not even about
attitude first it's about get your
financial mental get your Montee mental
right okay because if you're satisfied
if you're happy where you are
financially why would you sell anything
else look let's face it your own
commission you get paid to sell things
you get paid to close deals you get paid
to follow up only when it works okay
number one get your money mindset right
you got to know how to practice okay so
this is what we're gonna do
which one of these three do you want to
handle right now let's go with the price
design I feel like I'm on The Price is
Right pick the objection son let this
let your people pick the one they're
having trouble with yeah so you give me
a price I'm gonna give you the objection
okay so it's gonna be we get your
property serviced it's gonna be a
hundred twenty bucks every every three
weeks
that's ridiculous no I understand yeah
so what do you understand if you
understand and then fix the price okay
okay listen I understand price too high
I get it look let's do it anyways that's
it's weird dude
but why would I do it anyway when the
price is too high right listen I
understand you know help me understand
you know how houses probably on a soggy
problem you guys are great it's a flop
but he's trying so what we got to do is
keep working with Miss like Elena going
to kick she's not gonna kick very hard
the first time right you shooting a gun
you're working with the gun you're
scared of it you're terrified of he's
never had a gun in your hand who's
scared of guns people that don't have
them right put one in your hand you play
with it bull dude that felt good that
felt strong yeah
next thing you are oh okay wait okay I
got a man the price is 119 a month let
me tell you what we did for you before
you object anything okay see I'm
controlling this I'm gonna control this
guy before you say yes or no let me tell
you what we do for you I just wear mine
sure yeah I don't have 119 for this I
understand you don't expect you to pay
119 if you don't have it but what you do
have is you have mosquitoes right and
let me tell you the downside of
mosquitoes let's say is a commercial
enterprise you got customers come over
here they leave your grocery store and
they get bitten by mosquitoes okay you
know what happens now they don't
remember the service they don't remember
your commitment they remember that's the
place I brought my kids they got to Zika
now let me just say this about the 119
if you'd like to pay it weekly it would
only be $30 a week and we take Visa
Mastercard or maybe we do some kind of
barter system with your grocery store
smile I'm smiling the whole time I'm
controlling things I don't let him talk
too much right because I know everything
that's gonna come out of his face right
now he's preparing to eject for me I
wanna I want to make sure he doesn't do
a lot of that what do you think yeah
i'ma have to take it back so other than
yourselves other than your said Oh see
now what we found out what it was right
it's the boss what if your boss says no
what do we do then
I don't know I don't know what to do I
mean if they say no I mean I guess it's
not gonna be no right right but why did
you agree to meet with me today cuz we
got mosquitos you got mosquitos man
Danny check in with the boss they just
come in right okay okay
now now now let me ask you something is
the boss of real thing how could you do
this no I well yeah I could probably do
it so you guys don't ask hard questions
man it's the boss the real thing man you
just put me off you just playing me off
right now cuz it'll 1:19 once y'all ask
people that yeah okay you want it you
want to take a different one yeah okay
I'm calling the guy I'm calling the guy
hey hey man I want to come over I'm
gonna give you an estimate on the Zika
protection all right I'm gonna come over
I'm gonna show you how to never have
another mosquito at your place again and
so it was this little cause I'm not
interested yeah I'm not I'm not
yeah I'm not interested okay now I'm
gonna do it to you but I want to know
how you're gonna handle that
okay all right so you call me it's a
coke yeah listen I'm just trying to call
you and you know so I can I give it a
your mosquitoes oh that's good man
that's good you got me that's how you
get rid of mosquitoes man yeah listen
listen what we can do is uh you know
it'll cost about a 120 bucks for us to
get rid of your mosquitoes so that's
good man send me a proposal so you're
opposed sure so William says you Senate
sent it to my office just almost done
you got my address yeah matter of fact
let me send us your office but let me
get your number let me text message you
see he did the number thing it'll blow
up in his face every time would show you
got my number man yo you got my number
man don't be stupid man coronae you went
off into space okay try it again
that was a flop all right yeah I'm not
interested you did a good up Tom not
interested I'm not interested no I
understand completely
listen um you know let's just go ahead
and do it anyways you flunk him right
here pick it back up to where I just
said hey look I'm not I don't I don't
see me it proposes what okay that's
where you got stumped by the lights you
just go back and you pick it up where he
he flunked he did good on the first part
of the call he got me to the place where
I said send me a proposal and pass not
interested send me a proposal man okay
uh let me get that uh let me get you
email so I can go ahead and since you
plop send me a proposal I love to our
lovely scent of repose yeah yeah gotta
keep you have to keep I love this in
your proposal yeah let's go ahead and
that's a great idea man by the way I've
already sent one in your email by the
way how many of you could send somebody
an email before the call was even
finished and I already have it sitting
there
directions locations confirmations a
place to text you in case you can't make
it okay
give this man a big hand huh come on
she likes being up here
so we got on the road again would it wit
farm you know what if I go ahead and
take care of mosquitos for free oh he's
coming up now he's coming up with some
stuff how many even come up with good
ideas after the deal is done how
important do you think sales is to
whoever's listening to whatever they
want to do in their career the most
important if you ask me it all starts
with sales no matter what your business
is
someone's got to sell someone on
something period you know you're gonna
sell them or they're gonna sell you I
mean at the end of the day sales is
everything at the end of the day I have
a I have a client that's a dentist right
yeah one of the brightest most brilliant
dentist on the planet it has a hugely
successful practice knows exactly how to
drive traffic into into his practice
knows exactly what to do
builds of VT it's been going on for
about four and a half years obviously
he's busy but finally gets it done that
he wants to basically teach other
dentists how to how to grow their
business absolutely he wants to teach
other dentists how to grow their
business and do it he does yeah yeah
because a lot of those dentists out
there you know they're not making much
money Yeah right
and they could be oh they could be if
they do exactly what he teach he didn't
get there because he didn't know sales
he got there because he drove traffic
right understood that numbers are what
matters uh-huh so he drove traffic to
his dentistry he's not doing the same
thing with that he drove job his
dentistry and he trained his treatment
coordinators how to close business
selling evil well my favorite definition
of selling came from my very dear friend
Dan Sullivan who is brilliant and he
said that selling is getting someone
intellectually engaged in a future
result that's good for them in getting
them to emotionally commit to take
action to achieve that result so if you
just look at that definition it's
profound
getting someone intellectually engaged
in a bigger future that's good for them
and getting them to emotionally commit
to take action to achieve that result
well if you take out the word good for
them then selling could be evil okay
meaning
Martin Luther King got people
intellectually engaged in a future
result and got them to commit to take
action mother Teresa did John F Kennedy
did well so does every sales person on
the planet so did Hitler Hitler got
people intellectually and emotionally
engaged in a future result that murdered
people wasn't good in that standpoint
but saying that selling is evil is like
saying oxygen is evil oxygen is bad the
the the the human body no organism could
survive without oxygen no business can
survive no country can survive no
economy can survive and be free without
sales sales is the oxygen that makes all
of it work you eliminate sales people
you've eliminated the entire sales force
most people learn what it is they know
about cars about financial instruments
about plumbing about anything more from
sales people than they do from school
it's the sales people that are
incentivized to actually sell a product
or service because they might actually
make some money or Commission that are
out there educating people about it
think about all of the things we know in
our life that we learned about because
we went into a store and someone told us
about it I mean you know if you go to a
you know department store and someone
starts explaining how to use a DVD
player I mean it's not like you're
sitting at home watching the documentary
on you know how to a DVD player work so
I mean you learn that stuff from sales
people so not only are sales people not
evil salespeople are saviors
marketers are saviours they are the
carriers of messages all over the world
every significant thing that has ever
happened in mankind came because someone
was incentivized to sell it
partnership is a very very overused word
in many circumstances the word
partnership means lack of sales okay so
since you don't have any revenue you say
but we have very promising partnerships
in other words its total [ __ ]
most partnerships are total [ __ ]
there's only one thing that you care
about its sales remember this is the
most important thing I tell you tonight
sales fixes everything
okay Nobles partnership nothing
strategic you're either selling or
you're not selling partnerships are both
if you want to apply a more
sophisticated test to a partnership when
you form a partnership did you boot
Excel and either lower costs or increase
sales that's it because if you form a
partnership and it doesn't force you to
recalculate your financials it's total
[ __ ] okay that's the test
it is a spreadsheet test for
partnerships most partnerships you
announce something to egomaniac CEOs who
don't know anything about the business
go to a press conference your mouse this
great thing and then nothing happens the
Middle's and the bottoms of your
organization can't stand each other
nothing happens okay so use the
spreadsheet test don't form partnership
instead focus on sales focus on sales I
swear to you that most entrepreneurs use
the p-word in order to blow smoke
because they cannot use the S word sales
the ideal number of times use your
partnership in a presentation is one
like just say it once you have one
partnership but if you start spitting it
out like it's the key strategic strength
for your company oh my god you are in
deep trouble okay but generally speaking
unless it changes your spreadsheet
partnerships are [ __ ] now I've got a
special bonus cup that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the best live 30 questions of the
day it's not enough to just watch a
video you have to do something about it
so pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets yet get them for free by
checking the link in the description
below here we go
number one how do you need to rethink
your sales pitch number two how can you
practice your new pitch this week and
number three what's the typical sales
person that you don't want to become and
if you're doing the best live 30
challenge with me put a hashtag best
live 30 in the comments below we want to
celebrate you people are afraid of
selling you're afraid you're gonna get
rejected you're afraid you're gonna be
seen as a greedy slimy selfish
salesperson the reality though is you
offer a fantastic product or service you
can help people and if you can't sell to
them they may never get the help that
they so desperately need you can do
sales in an ethical way that are chuh to
your core values
you must your business and your
customers depend on it so I used to have
a big aversion to selling I used to
think you know you have to have a big
ego to do I didn't want to rip people
off I didn't want people to think that I
was trying to you know squeeze them out
of money I didn't want to get rejected
all of the typical fears that I think
people have when they get into sales and
I still don't use sales as my primary
tactic to go out and get business but
when you see an opportunity to help
somebody you have to give them your best
effort to help them and I had to get
more into sales because I saw
entrepreneurs who were struggling who
were not getting the help that they
needed and I knew it can help them but I
wasn't really passionate about selling
what I was selling I was constantly
worried and living in fear and when you
live in fear you don't make smart
decisions and I got more into it because
I saw people who were failing who who
should have used my help who I could
have helped and I didn't step up and
then they failed and they went out of
business and they made bad mistakes I
own that that's my response that was my
fault
I could have helped and I didn't I
should have sold myself harder and I
didn't and I let everybody down I let
them down I let myself down and in a
broader sense I let my family down my
community down I have responsibility to
grow this business and to help more
people and that involves me selling
myself so fast forward to today I had
two guys in my morning show who wanted
to be thought leaders they wanted to
have books they went to be speakers he
wanted to be at the front of the room
they wanted to build their social media
accounts and profiles they wanted to be
seen recognized as experts in their
industries thought leaders I do a
workshop twice a year in Toronto for
three days helping people make money as
thought leaders and I break down my
exact strategies how we're going on
YouTube how are going Instagram what
your content strategy how to make videos
how to come up with ideas how to create
content how to win how to get speaking
gigs how to get a book deal all of it be
me be the Evan Carmichael of your
industry I break down how to do it but
not just a breakdown not just hey let's
sit in the room and learn from ideas
we're gonna work with you to do it I
take 15 people twice a year and I work
through exactly how to do it and then
you're taking your phone out and you're
making content you're making videos and
I'm gonna be sitting there talking to
you at helping you do it then you get in
front of the camera and you have to make
a video and I'm gonna be behind the
camera with my team telling you nope no
again do it again and say it like this
nope not quiet nope keep going a lot of
personalized one-on-one mentorship if
you want to be a thought leader it's
among the best training in the world you
need to do it if you have the budget you
can make the time free you should come
out and do it and some talk to these two
people who want to be thought leaders
and I have the knowledge and I have the
training to help them I think that
three-day event should be something that
they at least are aware of and so with
one of them I walk through the entire
process of what I cover in the event and
I'm trying to do it in a way that brings
them value obviously and then the other
one I quickly mentioned it and then
followed up in the DM on Instagram to
say hey here's the event I think it'd be
good for you maybe they come maybe they
don't come maybe some of them feel like
they're being sold to I don't think so
because it was when it's genuine when
they can feel your passion and love and
energy and care and desire to help them
that's what breaks through if you don't
actually care about the end consumer if
you see somebody come into the other
person's my next car that person is my
next suit that person is my next XYZ
right my next watch if that's the
mindset and attitude then they won't
feel the care they're gonna feel like
they're being sold to and being ripped
off but when you have the energy
compassion heart to help and you know
that this is the thing that they should
do I think it's your responsibility
and tell them about it when you believe
in what you're selling and when you
believe that it's actually the right
thing for that person it's your
responsibility to sell it if you want to
join the best life 30 challenge click
the link right here below me or if you
want more videos on how to sell better
check out the playlist right there next
to me continue to believe and I'll see
you soon